hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
beim ein video leute ich hoffe euch
jetzt gut irgendwie fehlt mir ist gerade
mal auf meine haare ich habe die vor
ungefähr eineinhalb monaten oder zwei
monaten blond gefärbten es ist ein
komplett wieder weg warum wachsen so
schnell ja ich hab natürlich euch geht's
gut in den letzten zwei tagen kam jetzt
kein video ich war noch etwas in münchen
habe es deswegen nicht geschafft dieses
video zum beispiel habe ich schon etwas
länger geplant aber es ist irgendwie ist
jetzt auf die reihe bekommen also ich
hab ja ab und zu mal ins netz oder auch
öffentlich das heißt jeder kann mir dort
snap schicken also wenn ihr mich dann
noch nicht gerettet habe dann mach das
jetzt schnell 123 dreieinhalb und man
kriegt ja wirklich ab und zu sachen
zugeschickt die sind wirklich komplett
krank manche sachen sind auch echt
lustig aber manchmal denke ich mir recht
warum ihr habt ihr wahrscheinlich am
titel schon gelesen heute geht es um die
zehn schlimmsten snapshot post von so
rich kids also halt so abgehobene
[ __ ] die halt wirklich ziemlich
reiche eltern haben und das auch
öffentlich so auf social media zeigen
und eigentlich indirekt sagen wollen ich
bin geil als du natürlich wird das ist
auch nicht zu negativ darstellen
vieles davon ist doch echt witzig aber
einige sachen dann schon echt krass und
das muss dann will ich auch nicht sein
leute ich will eigentlich gar nicht
lange lagern nun bevor wir anfangen
wollte gar nicht sagen
am sonntag kommt endlich ein video wir
haben da glaube ich drei monate dran
gesessen jemanden ganz kurzer ausschnitt
es ist auf jeden fall dass geiste video
geworden was je auf youtube hochgeladen
wurde und er freut sich auf sonntag ich
bin schon ziemlich gespannt wie's
löchern kommen okay leute
wir fangen an mit dem ersten snap den
nicht gefunden habe und zwar ist es
dieser hier wanted weapons sack also auf
deutsch übersetzt ich wollte ihnen
gelten meine eltern nerven mich schon
wieder so und zwar haben wir hier einen
lamborghini in grün
das problem ist nur er wollte lieber
geld haben
das ist wirklich so ein problem ich kann
es auch komplett nachvollziehen ich
meine ist bei mir genauso wenn man mir
in la bohème stellt der grün ist eher
das geht doch nicht ehrlich leute das
geht nicht da bist du dumm das ding
kostet keine ahnung 200 300.000 euro und
du willst gelb dann las ich jedoch
umlackieren für 1000 euro beim gold also
da kann man sich echt zu fragen wie
können eltern ihr kind so erziehen dass
es so wenig weiß mit geld umzugehen paar
leute kommen wir zum nächsten foto oder
das ist das hier auf deutsch übersetzt
ich könnte mich nicht entscheiden körper
hat mir alle fünf geholt also
normalerweise wenn man ein iphone hat
und sich eine hülle dazu kauft kann man
sich eine farbe aussuchen problem
hierbei ist nur um das ist das iphone 5
c und das gab's halt in fünf
verschiedenen farben also weiß gelb grün
blau und rot anscheinend wusste der papa
dann nicht welches die lieblingsfarbe
ist und dachte sich com kaufe ich
einfach mal alle fünf also dafür mehr
ich dir heute das nächste foto ist
dieses hier knüpft eigentlich ziemlich
dazu an und zwar hat er hier anscheinend
ein neues iphone bekommen und was kann
man natürlich besseres machen als ein
altes iphone zu verkaufen oder
vielleicht an jemanden zu verschenken
da nicht so viel geld hat richtig eine
fette champagner flasche kaufen und
diese als bilder tür benutzen und das
iphone zerstören und das wichtigste ist
natürlich den autoschlüssel noch schön
auf dem bild zu positionieren aktion die
uhr darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen
kommen wir zum nächsten bild das fand
ich eigentlich sogar echt ziemlich
lustig und zwar haben wir hier ein ganz
normales spiel also ihr kennt
wahrscheinlich ist es länger spielt wo
man halt diese katze starb das foto
entstand an einer privaten schule das
heißt eine schule man geld bezahlen muss
und auch so privatschulen sind dann
meistens auch kinder wo die eltern etwas
zu viel geld haben ich meine man muss ja
auch nicht auf eine schule gehen wo man
kein geld bezahlen muss und die dachten
sicher kommen spielen wir mal alles
schön mit unseren iphones länger ich
mein wenn das kaputtgeht kaufen halten
neues so lautet das nächste foto ist
dieses hier finde ich eigentlich auch
ziemlich lustig
und zwar schreibt er dazu ich hoffe der
mathelehrer akzeptiert das so dem ist
anscheinend das papier ausgegangen
und was macht man wenn man kein papier
hat richtig man schreibt einfach aufs
ipad wahrscheinlich auch noch mit einem
permanent marker jetzt muss ich aber mal
kurz mal durchrechnen ob du richtig
gerechnet hast nein das kann schon gar
nicht sein die erste tat bot doch doch
doch du glaubst das ist richtig es eher
was so für die neunte klasse
aber ja ist richtig so leute hier ist
das nächste foto und dazu muss ich erst
mal sagen schönes foto nur im t shirt zu
produzieren und irgendwas drauf zu
drucken kann ja eigentlich fast jeder
wenn da aber so leichtsinnig draufsteht
stop being tue also hört auf arm zu sein
ich habe sie sich ganz einfach dann hat
sie auch noch so chanel luftballons ist
ja eine relativ teure marke und ich
glaube das bad ist auch relativ cool
sogar mit kamin im hintergrund aber
mädel ich kann dir sagen es gibt auch
menschen die kommen auf die welt und
haben nicht sofort reiche eltern und da
bringt es auch nichts wenn man sich ein
t-shirt anzieht wo draufsteht höher auf
arm zu sein na ja da ist das nächste
bild finde ich echt geil und zwar louis
vitton erkennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle
ist eine relativ exklusive marke wenn
man sich der tasche oder rucksack auf
ist man schnell mal so mit 17 dabei
hatte 1000 euro für eine tasche oder
rucksack ist schon relativ sportlich
wenn man dann aber überhaupt nicht weiß
was mit seinem geld anstellen soll
richtig dann lässt man sich einfach ein
football von louis vitton anfertigen ich
google jetzt mal kurz wie teuer das ding
ist also ich habe jetzt nur einen motor
fußball gefunden also kein futter
sondern fußball gut ist ja eigentlich
auch ein football aber ihr seht
wahrscheinlich ein unterschied und das
ding kostet 1500 euro für den fußball
der wahrscheinlich nicht mal gut ist
aber dass wenn ich wenigstens doch
lustig so leute und das hier ist das
nächste foto da schreibt jemand dort
treibt person food also diese wörter
pässen food deute ich so ein bisschen
abwertendes essen so bauern es mäßig was
halt so sich irgendwie jeder leisten
kann also in diesem beispiel halt mehr
donald erhält hat seine rolex davor und
posthalter übels arrogant hey komm ich
dachte ich probiere auch mal dieses
bauern essen dick leiter ich hoffe
die spucken die richtig auf den big mac
so leicht und kommt zum schluss zu
meinem favoriten crashs ersten driving
das ist jetzt halt nur in bentley kostet
100.000 weniger aber trotzdem noch über
100000 world problems auf jeden fall
kenne ich ich bin auch manchmal meinem
auto und denkt scheiße
das heißt sie gestern erst den lambo
kaputt gemacht hast du heute nun muss
sagen das leben kann echt so gemein sein
er sollte das waren meine zehn
schlimmsten snapshot post von spitz die
ich so ermitteln konnte wenn ihr bock
hat er sich das ganze auch mit instagram
rich kids mache last man doch nach oben
da bei ich bin mal gespannt wie viele
lecks verschaffen und dann kommt der
nächste projekt auf jeden fall snapshot
und fenster gemacht und wir sehen uns
dann morgen wieder fahren gibt es ein
cooles neues video also haut rein 15 uhr
einschalten
es kommt immer um 15 uhr